Do you know the Republicans want to ban corn?
Huh? What?
Who are you? Oh,
I'm Project 2025. I'm everywhere.
Forget about doors, forget about privacy
if Trump wants to ban all the fun stuff
to make sure that you're not doing any of it.
I've heard this is just propaganda.
Republicans can't ban us from looking at women on the internet.
I mean, what are you gonna ban?
Only fans? Oh no,
they wanna make it a crime.
Project 2025 literally says
people who produce it and distributed should be imprisoned
on page No. 5.
It's a banger right out of the gate.
Okay, but Trump and Project 2025 are not the same thing.
Most of the people who wrote Project 2025 work for Trump.
I'll let you finish legally.